we are resolved to continue imposing
massive costs on russia
costs that will further isolate russia
from the international financial system
and our economies
in coordination with president biden
president macron
bundes cancer schultz and prime minister
draghi
as well as prime minister trudeau and
prime minister johnson
we considered a significant
tightening of our international response
the european union and its partners are
working to [ __ ] putin's ability to
finance his war machine
i will now propose to eu leaders the
following measures first
we commit to ensuring that a certain
number of russian banks are removed from
swift
this will ensure
that these banks are disconnected from
the international financial system
and harm their ability to operate
globally
we will paralyze the assets of russia's
central bank
this will freeze its transactions
and it will made it impossible for the
central bank to liquidate assets
we will work to prohibit russian
oligarchs
from using their financial assets on our
markets
all of these measures
will significantly harm putin's ability
to finance his war
putin embarked on a path
aiming to destroy ukraine
but what he is also doing in fact
is destroying the future of his own
country